we have breaking news from Paris where
singer Chris Brown and two others are in
custody for a suspected rape French
police say that Brown was detained
yesterday after a 24 year old woman
filed a complaint Brown's bodyguard and
another unnamed person are also being
held at this time Jericka Duncan is here
now as Brown's latest run-in with the
law
Jericho good morning good morning Gail
the woman reportedly met Brown and his
friends at a French nightclub before
going back to his nearby hotel where the
alleged incident took place last week
now brown faces potential charges
including aggravated rape and drug
infractions investigators reportedly
have two days to decide if they want to
charge him or let him go this is just
the latest in a string of serious
incidents the RMD singer has faced over
the last decade in 2009 you may remember
Brown pleaded guilty to felony assault
after beating his then-girlfriend
Rihanna just before the Grammy Awards he
served six years probation for that and
in 2016 he was arrested for assault with
a deadly weapon after an hours-long
standoff with police a woman then said
that she called 911 inside the home
saying Brown had threatened her with a
gun he was released on $250,000 bail now
the singers publicists that Sony Music
have not yet commented on these new
allegations Fiona
all right Eureka thank you